I will always say right time right
person if you catch them right at that
moment just being consistent with what
you're doing Kate Hill the top performer
for wiser in 2022 to 2023 and the first
female ever top performer in the
company's history so how does she do it
your first year you're still learning so
much I'm probably halfway there like in
terms of being an expert but so this is
what you're going to learn in this
week's episode the importance of
worldclass Basics and why you need to
understand your success metrics it comes
back down to the basics again just doing
every little thing you can even if it's
not going well why it's so important to
have a niche and how to leverage your
network to grow your recruitment debts I
worked on an account and it was such a
hard account to crack at first once
you're in it and you've like cracked
what they like how to unlock your
self-confidence and why Kate initially
struggled at the start of her
recruitment career and lastly her most
effective new business generation
techniques and how she landed her best
client that generated over 100k worth of
fees let's get into this week's episode
Kate welcome to the podcast
thanks looking forward to breaking down
this four and a bit years of a journey
you've been on uh obviously we've met a
couple of times you've come to the
I feel like you've come to the obviously
you came to the last live podcast event
because Louis was on the panel had to
support leis yeah I had to and then did
you come I feel like you've come to one
before no the last one in London I feel
like some of the wiser team were there I
don't know if you there I I don't think
I was there but the wiser team probably
would have been um so today we're going
to talk about this this journey you've
been on yeah right um so just to give
everyone the career highlights uh of uh
your career so far so been working the
only job you've had in recruitment is
with wiser Elite yeah so your world is
Tech sales it is and I'm just going to
give everyone let me know if any of this
is wrong by the way so uh over the last
couple years obviously you started as a
researcher right yeah right the bottom
right at the bottom sourcing a bunch of
different roles just doing the work for
everyone basically yeah doing the work
for everyone yeah Okay cool so I've got
here so we started with 2021 right 20 to
2021 yeah your Billings was 110k yeah 21
to 20 uh two 200k so broke the 200k mark
and then last year um the uh last
Financial year 20 2022 2023 was 210k
yeah and that meant that you was the top
performer that year let's go the first
female top biller let's go first female
principal as well yeah proud of those
ones aren't you very proud should be up
the girls so we're going to unpack this
this journey that uh you've gone on to
get to that point cuz I know it's it's
been difficult ult it's been challenging
you've learned along a lot along the way
but let's let's start with a million
pound question let's hear your take on
what you believe to be the the common
characteristics and traits that make up
a highly successful recruiter in today's
market yeah I mean I think with the with
the state of the market at the moment
the main thing and I'm sure everyone
would say this is that grit
determination but on the other side of
things like having that patience as well
within the market like at the moment
there's times where you just want to get
[__] done basically quickly and you
actually have to sometime take a step
back and and think right what would
actually be the good decision in this
situation because it's easy to just go
straight into it but also as well that
creativity like at the moment standing
out in Recruitment and being the one
that clients want to speak to and
candidates want to speak to you need to
think of ways to like cut through that
noise and be creative with stuff so I
think it's the combination of
competitiveness grit determination but
not going
hell for letter and taking a step back
and being patient with
it yeah I think it's really sometimes
you're like forced to try different
things right if things aren't working
but cuz you're used to especially in a
good Market you're you're used to just
doing just doing it day by day the same
stuff and then when you actually get
pushed back you actually have to take a
step back and think wait how can I
change what I'm doing on a day-to-day
basis to like break through and whenn
new clients get candidates on the phone
in a different way what some let's just
talk about that then what are some of
the things that you changed over the
last six months or experimented with
that have worked haven't worked yeah I
think it's easy to just sit behind your
laptop and go on LinkedIn and just
message people what I've been trying to
do and why is really as well I've been
trying to do is use different methods
like I've been sending videos to
candidates and clients instead of just a
message um or voice notes as well like
we're not really a cold calling type
business we do a lot of of our stuff
more strategically I suppose um so I've
been sat there in a booth trying to do
these videos to clients like hey it's
Kate um what like looms or vid yards or
whatever just literally I've just been
doing it on normal my normal camera and
then just sending it on LinkedIn on a
direct message um and we've had some
really good feedback even if they're
like we're not hiring right now they've
been like love love that video love what
you're doing and then at least in maybe
a few months time when I reach out to
that client again to to bring them on I
remember Kate sending that video that
was really different from from other
people it's crazy right cuz video's been
around for a while now I think so the
fact that you're still getting those
sorts of responses is is a bit wild to
me yeah I think like it's what you say
and how you come across in the video I
think it's easy for people to have some
scripted response to it all I think if
you're just yourself and even make a bit
of a go on their profile see something
on their profile that like they've been
to something recently you comment on
that or you can see they've got a
picture with their family on LinkedIn
reference that like do something that's
not just hey see you hiring can I help
you yeah I'm going to have to ask you
then what we like cuz it you often I
found when I've done video Outreach
stuff like the first the the first few
that you do when you start doing them
are way worse than the ones towards when
you've done like a lot of them yeah
definitely what what did the ones sound
like when you first started like what
was you yeah cuz and then we can get you
to share like how the how you sort of
structure these now I know you said you
might reference different things it
depends on what you see but when you
first started sending this is what what
was you trying to say in the message was
it just hey are you hiring yeah I think
the amount of times as well you'd be
like get halfway through and then just
go [__] on it I do that so many times um
but I think yeah it at first it was
quite forced and and don't hate it's
Kate we're wise relite we do this we're
Tech sales quite robotic whereas
sometimes now I'd like slide into the
camera and be like
hey just bring some fun to it yeah bring
some fun to it and relax into it because
people will like find that funny and you
feel like sometimes you need to be
serious all the time it's actually like
sometimes even sending them I've done it
before where I've sent them the actual
bad version really and sent it and then
gone hope you hope you found that funny
noticed you're hiring account executives
that's quite cool and then just done
that and like people when you first
started very like serious quite like
yeah just stiff yeah quite stiff like
you know just keeping it very basic um
and now it's more just go with the flow
have a bit of fun did you find yourself
cuz I think sometimes why people don't
lean into that is they think this just
going to take ages to do cuz they're
always going to want to redo it did did
you find yourself doing that I think if
you take some if you have it in your
diary for example like to do an hour of
just some videos or voice notes or
whatever you'll be disciplined to do it
you don't have to do loads but if you
just have that time weekly or whatever
to do it then you'll get it done if you
have it in the diary then I don't if you
approach it the same with the voice
night but what what's like your typical
structure cuz I feel like if you're
sending a voice night or even a video I
don't think you should start it by
speaking about yourself personally no I
think it depends what your voice noting
them about sometimes it depends if it's
on the candidate or client side of
things because I do it to both if I'm
sending a voice note to a client to try
and win new business then I think the
most important thing is trying to solve
a problem for them straight away so
something like it's hard to attract
female talent in in SAS are you
experiencing that right now I'm working
with someone at the moment that and go
into it with like something in the
market that's happening right now that
is a problem and they can then switch on
to that straight away yeah that might be
top of mind for them yeah exactly that's
smart so yeah so you're leading with
some you're basically trying to make a
bit of an assumption that they might be
running into yeah and it's either like
are you struggling with with this and I
may have a solution for it or if you're
not struggling with it then yeah you're
still coming across like oh like he
understands and at Le yeah at least you
sound like an expert in in the market or
reference like something that's going on
in the tech market right now you always
want to be known in your Market as an
expert and so if you make that clear
right at the start and then like who the
hell is this girl then they'll trust you
more yeah I love that just just as you
mentioned it there it come it comes up a
lot so I'd love to hear your thoughts on
it cuz I know when we were looking
through the not some of your like
challenges early on was like really
understanding the Dynamics of the the
market and being confident about that
how long do you think it takes for
people to become a market expert like
you you may not be able to put a Time on
it but I think it's important for people
to know it's not going to be couple of
months like what how long do you think
it took you to be quite confident to
comment uh comment on the market
dynamics what's going on and have that
confidence around being an expert to
it's a it's a interesting one because I
think you'll never feel like you are
like you're learning every day
especially in the tech Market there's so
much of it going on I'm sometimes like
what does that mean that
ter but I think
um I'd say your your first year your
still learning so much I think um it's
helpful for us because we immerse
ourselves in the the that industry all
the time because we host regular events
webinars we have our communities that
have loads of tech sales people in them
so when I'm listening to webinars and
being at events I'm learning constantly
and that's what I would actually advise
to people in their space is go to events
of the industry that you're working in
because you're constantly learning and
speaking to the people that you're
trying to help but I'd say I genely
don't think there's a Time on it because
I'm still feel like I'm I'm probably
halfway there like in terms of being an
expert but and I I think it's an outside
looking in I'd be an expert but you can
be constantly learning new things about
the industry yeah I think that's the
right mindset to have right but I think
yeah like definitely 12 months plus oh
yeah 100% for sure definitely so you
took a couple attempts to parti your
probation which you tell me yeah yeah
what what was you struggling with why
why did it take a few few attempts for
for Kate to pass probation in that first
year I think it
was well I think coming in I was already
quite nervous because of the my
interview situation where which didn't
go quite well but they saw something in
me so they were like right we'll bring
her in there's some there's traits
within that girl that I think could be
good um I think for me it was like the
discipline of recruit M that I couldn't
get my head around and in WIS Rel as
well we're very like not strict on do
these kpes do this but just like having
that discipline and I think at first I
was a bit kind of just Whispering
through like okay um uh and also I just
found it really hard to get my head
around the tech Market at first um but
once I realized that just talking to
people and being yourself and trying to
help them and understand what they're
looking for that's actually the whole
thing you meant to do you're not
actually meant to be the genius Tech
person you're just that your your job is
to really understand what's important to
these people yeah and I love talking to
people and so when I actually realize
that this job is all about helping
someone and making them find their like
dream role and if you really unpack that
and understand it then you can always
ask PE people around you like questions
around i' I've found out this about this
person who do you think they'd be best
suited to in your early stages of your
career so if I'm if I'm someone
listening and I've enter the recruitment
industry this year which might be just
uh a lot of people describe it as like a
typical Market or like a a challenging a
typical challenging Market where you've
like you said you've got to commit to
try and stand out you've got to work
hard to to get the opportunities that
that you want like what what would your
advice be to them what would what should
be really committing to becoming better
at what should they be doing in those
first 6 12 months I think the biggest
thing for me was to throw yourself into
situations that you don't want to do so
one of my worst things to do with with
like managers and stuff is like role
plays stuff oh it's just so stiff it's
like you when you have to do that and
you're like doing a pretend regge call
or like trying to talk to a candidate
but I think it's one of the most
important things you can do is like put
yourself out there to be like can we
practice this as if I'm on a candidate
call or can we do like can I pitch wiser
Elite to you cuz I'll have to do that in
front of clients soon but also go into
as to go to meetings and asked to listen
into candidate calls in my early stages
when I'd go to meetings with Jack or Lou
or whatever I'd just sit there and like
just take it all in soak it all in like
everything that they were saying and you
even start to realize you said you then
start to say certain phrases that you're
saying I was like oh God Jack says
that yeah you start picking up on things
yeah let me ask you this then what did
Kate's reg's candidate reg calls sound
like in that first year compared to how
they sound like now oh my God it used to
sound like I was literally sat there
like um and what are you looking for in
your next role um I think now um a big
thing for me is that I just have I want
always at the start just want to have
that conver like normal friendly
conversation with them about what
they're doing at the weekend what they
like what they've done last week um but
it's the the flowing like nature of it
now it used to fall very this question
this question this question this
question now it flows I feel like it
flows in between um and just the tone of
it now seems so much more chilled but if
you go into it like I'm just talking to
a mate at the
pub then you can you can go with it more
what about I feel like often times what
people have to get better at is not
taking the first answer for what it is
in what in what way like if I say Katie
talk me through like why we're here
today like what is it that prompted you
to to come back to me and you say look
they've set unrealistic targets I've had
enough of it which is why I want to move
yeah I feel like a lot of people when
they're early on would write that down
tick reason for leaving is that and then
move on to the next question but it's
often the like why behind that or the
the third why that you ask that really
helps you understand what what's
important to this person or why this
person is doing what they're doing so
have you had to get better at that yeah
I think it's a really easy thing for
candidates when you're on the phone to
them to say and I when you say it's
really interesting to know why you're
actually looking for a new role when
you've only been there for seven months
and they'll go I'm just curious to know
what's out there it's like you're not
curious to know what's out there you
wouldn't be on the phone to me if that
was the case and and then just really
trying to dig into that so I said I'll
say is there anything now in your
current role that you change like is
there anything now in your current role
that you change and then you they start
to stay stuff where you're like ah so
that's what it is um like they they've
not mentioned at all before that they go
into the office five days a week and all
of a sudden they're like oh yeah I mean
I'm I've got a wife now and I'd quite
like a bit more of a flexible rol you
never said that when I asked what what
you'd want so I think um like getting
them to like pull it back again and a
good question I always think to ask when
you're asking them what they're looking
for is is there anything that I could
put in front of you right now that you
wouldn't like because people go
I'm I'm really open I'd look at anything
and then you start to put opportunities
in front of them they're like no no no I
said I thought you were open to anything
but if you say for example in the tech
space I'm working with mtech companies
HR tech companies would you look at them
or you more on the cyber security
technical type opportuni they're like oh
no actually yeah I think I'm more on the
technical side of things I was like oh
good because I was actually just about
to tell you more about HR and mtech so
actually saying what do you not want as
opposed to what do you want yeah nice
that's great that's a great
Point uh like just curious on this one
for people specifically in your space
how have you had how have you got better
at seeing through the [__] of salese
cuz that must be hard they they do
[__] a lot cuz you're dealing with
people that that sell it's it's a skill
it's something that they're if you're
you're dealing now more at the senior
end they count executiv so yeah they
should be pretty good at their craft so
you'd like to think you tell me
otherwise but you'd like think that
these people are quite effective at
selling themselves I'm sure they over
sell inflate their numbers whatever so
how how have you got better at like
cutting
through sometimes the The Mirage of what
they give you of like yeah I'm the
[__] top sales person on the top AE
and you're like are you though are you
how how have you got better at that I
think the the the good thing about
talking to salespeople is that they're
great to talk to like as in in
comparison to maybe some other
Industries within recruitment
they are great to have a conversation
with I think in terms of knowing whether
they're chatting [__] is um if you're
this comes back to the expert in the
market thing if you know the market well
you are aware of companies and what
they're doing so for example you might
have spoken to someone from the same
business and they've told you that all
come all all the reps are
underperforming and you're like oh
really that's funny because you're
saying you're on 110% of Target but that
only comes from experience and talking
to loads of people all the time which is
why I'll always say even if you've not
got roles for the right people
constantly be speaking to AES like
weekly like fif like 10 15 good solid
account exacts and try and pull Market
information out of them even if you
don't have any thought anything for them
right now because you'll find out that
then you can when you're on calls with
other people you're thinking your head
this guy's this guy's not chatting the
right stuff because I spoke to someone
last week from the same company and then
have you found yourself being more
comfortable challenging people on like
if I if I say to you Kate look like
everyone's underperforming I'm you know
I've got a team of sdls that aren't
getting me leads or whatever and you've
picked up information that actually I'm
not sure that's true is have you had to
be more comfortable challenging people I
think I I feel it's one of those things
on a call it's hard it would be hard to
be like oh you're wrong actually because
I heard that from someone last week but
I think it's more from your side in the
Trust of the candidate and whether you'd
want to put them forward for that role
because you'd be like I don't think we
this guy's trustworthy yeah fair so
obviously the the year just gone was was
a big year for you right yeah obviously
I think what people always interested to
know is like what what did you do
different I think you clearly
had you went from you you broke the 100k
Mark but then you know two years back to
back you then managed to break the 200k
mark so like if I was to put you in the
shoes of you had that year where you did
110 yeah and you're looking into the
next year and you're thinking how can I
break how can I get double what I've
just
done like when when you was in that
position what were some of the things
that you were thinking that you needed
to double down on or like how was you
thinking about getting to that next
point cuz I think that that's
interesting right cuz when you get to
that point and then you're like [__]
right now how am I going to get double
out of what I've just I know and then
you go back to zero and you're like oh
here we go again exactly so like how did
you how did you think about that going
into to that year cuz then you've
managed to maintain that so how how do
you think about that I think the best
way to think about it is not thinking
about the end goal like I'm really I've
started to really try and teach myself
it's really easy when you like when
you're you're top and then you go
everyone goes back to zero again on a
leaderboard and you're like oh we start
again and it's my what I've been trying
to think um and what I was trying to
think then was if you take day by day
instead of like thinking about the end
so day by day week by week then you'll
get to where you want to get to so in
the day what can you do in that day to
win is that that you have to do one more
extra call regge call is it that you
need to like just reach out to two more
clients and once you've done that in a
day you've done everything you can do in
that day if you do that five days you've
won that week and you just keep doing so
breaking it down break it down yeah and
that's that's one of my I'd say biggest
things is if you in the day you in the
week if you're in the week you in the
month if you're in the month you in the
year that's how you like to think about
it yeah we'll get back to the episode in
just one minute but today I wanted to
tell you about our partners sourcewell
the industry-leading business
development and head hunting platform
I'm a sourcewell user myself and it's
been an absolute GameChanger when it
comes to crafting personalized Outreach
it's not only quick and easy but you can
tap into custom variables automate
follow-ups and use multiple channels
like the phone LinkedIn email and more
to accelerate results users report an
average increase of 56% in qualified
response rates and when you're using it
it's easy to see why AI powered tools
like content coach and wh GPT improve
your chances of not ending up in spam
something that's become increasingly
challenging with Google's recent
deliverability changes it also tracks
all of your activity into your CRM keeps
your data clean and lets you know who
you need to reach out to and when so you
can spend more time on what you're good
at recruiting not admin so if you're
serious about being the best at what you
do join me and thousands of recruiters
who have chosen sourcewell to
revolutionize their Outreach approach
book a demo with sourcewell and mention
the recruitment mentors podcast to enjoy
an extra 50 phone and 50 email credits
per user and this exclusive offer will
save you Circ £500 and more and it's
only available until March the 31st
click the link in the episode
description or you can head to
source.com
slemo so how let's just break this down
a bit then cuz I think you shared with
me when we prepared for this yeah like
you said it quite a few times but you
was big on the basics right so I feel
like this is part part of it so
regardless of I've spoken quite a lot
about it we literally did a training
session on this yesterday about
basically reflecting on the year and
goal setting and the big chunk of it is
what you're talking about it's like if
my if I've set myself the target of of
breaking 300K yeah then if I look at
that number going into next year that
that can feel overwhelming and it's like
how the how am I going to do that but
then as soon as you start breaking it
down firstly to Quarters on what you
need to be doing on a quarterly basis
but then you understand what your
average deal size is and then you know
what you need to be doing on a uh weekly
monthly uh basis to get to the end point
of 300K but then I think what the best
recruiters do and understand is in order
for me to do have 100K quarter what the
might inputs need to be yeah how many
candidate regge calls do I need to have
how many client meetings do I need to
have how many jobs on do I need to have
it's understanding what those success
metrics are and I feel like when you
talk about the the basics that's
ultimately what you're talking about
it's like doing the things that you know
add up that help you win the day that
help you win the week that help you win
the year so what what for you like if
you think about your best year uh I
don't know if you've looked at this but
like what were like the the core
activities that clearly you did
consistently most of the time that
resulted in you winning the year I
probably wouldn't know exact numbers but
I think it actually again goes right
down to the first thing which is
speaking to the most people that you can
I always would say that my reged stats
like candidate calls were always really
really high and the reason that that was
beneficial was because if I didn't have
anything for them right at that moment
yeah it seems like a bit of a waste of
time but then a month later we'd bring
on a role and I would go back to my
talent pool we have talent pools of
candidates so 0er to two years
experience two to four and they're all
in RCM and I'd go back my all my stuff
would be organized there and be like
right I think these three could be good
for that get in touch with them and
without having to do a fresh
search so it's like using doing
everything you can and thinking about
what roles you could bring on in two
months time but speaking to that
candidate and thinking it's still worth
your time in that moment because it's so
easy when you're working on certain
accounts to be like I'm only going to
speak to people that will be right for
this role you need to think outside the
box and think but in 2 months I'm not
going to have these roles they're going
to be gone so I need to speak to people
that are going to be potentially good
for other stuff that was really
interesting to say that
because in this training session that we
did cuz we broke it down in like the
things I was just saying so um number of
C uh number of CVS to jobs jobs on like
the different like core things and I
said to Alicia who did the session like
what what do you like what would you
always want to make sure you're like
smashing every single month and she said
candidate meetings and clent meetings
because of what you just said it's what
you're also saying there is by you
always making sure that you're doing
that every single day every single week
you're gathering information you're
understanding more about the market
you're understanding more about the
people respect you like people respect
you for doing that I've had calls this
week where I've said look I don't really
have think from just looking at your
profile that we have anything for you
right now but my job is to connect with
high performing account Executives in
the market and I'm really Keen to have
this chat so that we can just understand
what you'd be looking for and when it
comes through to us I'll drop you a
message and just leave it like that and
they actually really appreciate it they
like really appreciate you taking the
time to speak to me when you might not
have anything
on what do you try and curious then like
what do you try and do like take one of
those calls for example yeah cuz I feel
like people listening might have had a
lot more of those conversations this
this year because they haven't had as
many jobs at them definitely what what
are some of the things you always try
and do on those calls that make when you
get off them you're like you know what
that was a good call what are some of
the things you always trying to trying
to do the experience you're trying to
create the the types of things you're
trying to Showcase and that call to that
person I think initially when you're
speaking to them at the start you want
to give them uh I suppose like who like
give them the intro about who you are
not just straight into right okay so
what have you done I'll always be like
just to give you a bit of a background
about me um been at WIS for for a b
years or whatever um I specialize purely
in account executive Recruitment and I'm
always just really Keen to to chat to to
people in the space Network um and
hopefully partner together at some point
um whether that's now or in the future
and then we'll do a normal regge call
like you know understanding their
numbers targets what they'd be looking
for why they're looking to leave and
then when you speak to them again when
you might have a role they like how you
can reference back to what you've said M
so you're like I remember when we spoke
two weeks like three two three weeks ago
you were saying that um I don't know the
the targets were unrealistic like they
they changed at all and people are like
oh she remembers that that's that's
great well makes you it makes them feel
like you actually listened yeah cuz
sometimes it's easy especially in
recruitment to just feel like people are
just like on the other end of the phone
like typing away and also there's about
there's a lot of people out there that
just want to speak to people that are
relevant for them right at that moment
so in that time if you have a nice 10 15
minute com you don't have to keep it
long like sometimes a redge call can be
30 minutes but if you don't have
anything for for them that right now you
don't want to waste their time too much
and then get to the end and be like yep
we have no roles for you but um I think
as well setting that at the start though
yeah that's why that intro is important
that intro is really important and
making sure that you've done that right
at the beginning so you don't get to the
end and you've done a whole asking them
about everything and then they're like
so what what if you got at the moment
it's like nothing nothing for you yeah
um so um I think people when comes to it
when they're actually as well in their
future career when they're looking to
turn to a recruiter to partner with
they'll remember you for doing
that yeah cuz I feel like as well when
you've cuz now I'm sure you've got
plenty of stories where you spoke to
that person who didn't have anything for
initially but then 3 6 months later you
did so you can then also start
referencing that in your introduction
right it's like look I'll be honest uh
often times uh I don't always have
something for you immediately but uh a
lot of the people that I do end up
partnering with it's actually 3 six
months down the line so you could even
reference like names or like say place
like placements that you've you've done
with that or like even just being like
Oh it's funny because I actually had a
placed a guy last week that I spoke to
like six months ago and and now I'm
working with him again exactly so how do
you what obviously like surely then with
that approach which I think more and
more people need to just be on top of
definitely how like I think where often
times people do miss a trick is
if there isn't anything for them right
now they then sort of may not end up
speaking to them again or I think we've
all seen those LinkedIn posts where
people have said like just felt like
that it's very transactional and it's
like I only feel like Kate speak to me
when like she's got something for me
rather than um when she doesn't so like
what what does your follow-up look like
you said you put PE you like put people
in Talent PS but surely you've got to be
mindful of you know you've just spoken
to someone that right now you don't but
you're very confident that 6 months down
the line you probably well so what are
you doing in those 6 months to stay
front of mind to add value what does
that look like I think um what I always
say at the end of the call is um
understand that we don't have anything
right now but I'm always happy to answer
any questions on the market salary
advice um I'm also happy if you're in
any of the processes like let me know if
you want to ask any questions about it
like and I think that would stand out
from a lot of other recruiters that why
would you want to give advice like to
someone that's not in your own process
kind of thing but also making sure your
presence on LinkedIn is strong and
they're seeing your posts all the time
and adding value in that way we've also
just recently produced a salary survey
um at wiser and it's better for clients
obviously because they can see what to
pay um people but also we released it to
quite a few people and um a friend I
actually know from school um I sent it
to him he was like oh my God I'm paying
getting paid so much less than the
average count executive
um which actually then is actually
adding so much value for them because
they're like I can actually get a job at
X instead of so I think constantly just
adding value for them whether that's the
salary survey inviting them to our
events because you might speak to a
candidate and then we're like we've got
an event coming up it's um all about how
we did one recently on how AI can affect
the sales process come along and then
they come to the event you meet them in
person and then you've had that personal
connection with them as at at our events
too what so on on your best year what
what was like the most effective way
that you landed clients for you what
what ended up being you spoke earlier
about being open to trying different
things this year that's been really
important but like what what has ended
up being your most effective way like
what how did you land your your best
client in your best year
[Music]
um I I think it's funny because
sometimes it's like the most like cold
Outreach you can do and it's so so dull
and it what we always say it's literally
all about timing like I think you could
literally say hey hiring to a hiring
manager and they might have 10 AE roles
and go yeah we are actually we're
looking for an agency it's really good
timing or you do the most creative
campaign to them and they're like take
me off your
mailing so it's like I genuinely don't
think there's a right or wrong to it I
will always say right time right person
if you catch them right at that moment
and also just follow-ups so important
like I even think sometimes a good
followup is just bad timing on this one
John or whatever and they and then a lot
of the time they'll actually come back
and say even if it's a no go it it is
actually bad time at the moment Kate but
reach out to me in January and give you
like a time and at that point I'll put
it in my diary reach back out to John in
January and remind myself that but I
think I genuinely think it's I think
it's a timing thing I don't think there
a a Rhyme or Reason really yeah just
being consistent with consistent what
you're doing and like as I said I think
it just if you're a hiring manager or VP
of sales and you're sat there and in
your head you're thinking right I I
really want to work with an agency and
we need like specialist sales recruiters
and then all of a sudden my name pops up
on the phone light and I'm like
hey and it doesn't have to be a big
message like hey I work on AE
recruitment noes you're looking for a e
and working with ex candidate at the
moment send a little spec in and they're
like perfect just who I was looking for
is that how your best client came about
then just a cheeky cheeky little message
yeah and then also as it's it's I
suppose it's important as well to look
at like when you're actually trying to
hunt for who you want to BD is like look
at the sheer amount of roles that are on
on LinkedIn because like if you want to
if you want to bring on like a big
project and they have loads of a roles
like you want to go for that stuff
rather than it's Al it's good to go for
the single roll but you want the big
juicy stuff we'll get back to the the
episode in just one minute but today I'm
excited to talk to you about one of our
partners Firefish the recruitment CRM
that accelerates datadriven growth they
have just released their 2024
recruitment agency report based on
insights from over 200 agency leaders
the report offers unbelievable insights
into forecasts for the year ahead
enabling you to refine your strategy
Based on data rather than intuition here
are some of the stats I personally found
interesting from the report although
industry optimism has declined for the
third in a row growth signals remain
positive with 84% of agency leaders
expecting year-on-year sales growth this
year 47% of agency leaders plan to use a
contingency recruitment model in 2024
and 70% of agencies plan to use social
sourcing as their main candidate
attraction strategy in 2024 you can
access your free copy of the report and
start making data driven decisions about
your business by clicking the link in
the show notes and whilst you're there
if you wanted to check out how Firefish
could help your business grow this year
they very kindly offered a unique offer
to our community the recruitment mentors
podcast that's going to save you up to
£1,000 and this offer is only available
until March the 31st you can click the
link in the episode description and you
can also head to Firefish
software.com
rmp why did you why did you find
yourself niching down even more right
cuz I think yeah that that's quite
interesting about what we ended up doing
because a big how you can influence
becoming a top performer is definitely
looking at the market you're serving
what your average deal size is cuz your
your average deal size that year was
what between 15 to 20K right yeah so you
that means you had to average one deal
per month to get to where you got to
right so what made you Niche down into
that how did that come about cuz I feel
like that that's quite interesting and
people can take what you learn from that
into their own markets cuz if you can
increase your average deal size that
that has have such a huge impact on the
amount that you can bill it honestly
changed my Billings and my career having
those yeah I we we worked I worked on an
account um and at one point it was like
solely that account I was working on
which shows you you don't have to have
loads of accounts you can have one
account that's just like you just like
boom boom boom um and it was such a hard
account to crack at first and once I
knew what good looked like which I say
is one of the most important things once
you know what they think good is and you
can send that through but the Enterprise
side of things is all about high
percentage over Target strong tenure
loads of
experience
um but it takes time to to crack what
that what that is once you're in it and
you've like cracked what they like you
can just like be speaking to those
Enterprise people all the time ask for
referrals from candidates like they
might say to you not interested Kate but
then you go do you have anyone do you
have a friend in your space that's
looking they're like actually yeah I do
cuz they're like in quite a close
Network of these like Enterprise sales
people so it it sounded like it happened
actually a bit by accident then the well
the the ended up being in in an
environment where your average deal size
was a lot larger so you just came from
working with this one client it went
well like right I'm going to focus on
that yeah and then they had commercial
roles as well like less like like ones
that were lower deal value but they they
all of a sudden were like we want six of
these like and I was
like um and um them basically scale
their whole UK team um but it just shows
you that when you bring on something
like that where they're looking to maybe
build out a a UK function from the US
for example and they need to to scale by
6 to 10 employees but those average deal
sizes are 15 to 20K you can just work on
you would just need to work on one
client so you built the entire team yeah
I must got hard yeah it it was hard it
was hard but once I got into the swing
of it
um and also things like they wanted me
to do things like find female talent
instead of male talent and they wanted
diversity and it's also having to crack
all of that um but once I got into it I
knew exactly what they wanted and that's
from like really knowing the client and
I think it's so important as well my
point of contact was the internal
recruiter over there not like the head
of sales um and sometimes internal
wrecks can just not like external
recruiters but I got a really good
relationship with her made sure I
visited her in person in their offices
like went for for a lunch and coffees
and stuff like that and then we became
more of a partnership than uh I'm the AG
her problems exactly and helping her out
as opposed to her just CU sometimes they
don't like to work with agencies yeah of
course so I think where sometimes a lot
of recruiters for short is they they
have that experience and then they don't
Leverage What they've then done so like
I'm assuming now how are you leverage
leveraging that case study leveraging
what you've done to continue to land
more opportunities like that at that
Enterprise AE level how are you now
doing that yeah so in terms of like
winning new business CU I feel like
that's where sometimes often people like
they don't they don't do enough of that
oh yeah we really try and it's actually
interesting you say that because we've
been really trying to do that at the
moment creatively um win ways that say
I'm doing business development I'll send
them I noticed that they're hiring
Enterprise AES um we've built like a bit
of a really like nice looking like deck
that like is a bit of a reel of the
placements that I've made um the kind of
profiles that I found and it's actually
just on one slide and it's their faces
their titles and like it just shows you
like the six highers that we made for
the brand which is a really strong
company in the SAS space and I've been
just sending that out to Enterprise
sales directors being like hey I've just
scaled air tables team here in the in
the UK here here uh his here example of
the placements I've made do you show
anything else in that in terms of like
the important metrics on like time to
hire how long it took or not really
showcasing we there's actually another
slide that we've got um because we're
actually expanding into the US now as
well but someone else is doing that
Lauren Lauren yeah yeah um and so we've
got a slide that has the placements and
on the right hand side has number of
highers time to fill and how long we
were working with them for and if you
just have it on that one slide so when
clients can open it up on LinkedIn they
have to like download a file or anything
they can just see it visually right in
front of you they know exactly what
you've done how like what's been the
response from that that that quite smart
thing to do strong and also the visual
aid is good like it's easy enough to say
it in a voice note or say it on a
message like I helped scale by X and
stuff but if you look if if that just
came into your inbox and it's just a
picture in like a nice like creative way
with the photos very like like simple
writing of what we did they can just
look at it straight away and it's had
it's had strong feedback yeah if if
you're if you're listening right now and
you haven't created any assets like that
like this is the perfect time to do it
like looking back at the year I'm sure
there's going to be some successful
placements that you've done like it's
just so rather than yeah me relying on
Kate's word like there's evidence there
things that you can point out to go I've
done this for companies like yours can I
help you do it for you yeah another big
thing that I'd like really recommend and
has gone really well is getting the
hiring manager to a little video for you
so like K or wiser elite were were great
helping us scale here and we were really
struggling with diversity of hire Etc
and I've got one of the guys to do one
for me and I just was sending that out
to clients being like this is what we've
done but this is literally from the
horse's
mouth and that's a really good thing to
do so this leades me quite nicely then
as we round this out I think I don't
know about you but when you collect
stuff like that evidence almost yeah for
me that quiet that quietens a
self-doubt like you know when you have
someone saying Kate help me do this yeah
yeah yeah when like sometimes when you
wrestle with self-doubt self-confidence
like for me personally I just have a
folder of like testimonials and things
that we've done and like that that is
like the best yeah like that is the best
anecdote for me and I think but also if
you think about it in real time when
you're reaching out to these companies
how much more confident are you going to
be going into those conversation saying
look you might not need my help but I I
am the person that can partner with you
to do this I've done this for ex company
like yours yeah it's so true it is a
nice little confidence boost to be% I
was like it's not you saying it it's the
evidence yeah like when when when I when
I look at it back I'm like oh right yeah
did that um but it's it's true it's a
it's a it's a good thing to
recognize like what you've done apart
from just making the placements to hear
it from the client hear them saying
you've literally helped us scale here in
the UK you're like that's un real yeah I
did cuz talk the reason why I said that
is like talk talk share with us like
your your journey with your own um
mindset right cuz I know that's been a
real journey for you in terms of
self-confidence self-doubt and I such a
journey yeah just to like just add some
more context where I see this more
prevalent in my experience from the
people I spoke to is definitely more
women for sure in recruitment so the
fact that you were the first female top
biller the first um princip uh female
principal what that also means is that
Kate Kate had no one to look at to go oh
she like she's done what I'm trying to
do you had to be the the you know the
first person to do that right which in
itself presents a challenge if I'm in
your business I can look at Lewis I can
look at no whatever and go they they're
they're me like I I can get to where
they've got to like I've got like a run
model there yeah which is why 50% of the
women that I reach out to to come on
this podcast will respond of I'm not
sure I'm credible enough I'm not sure
that that's really sad that's just been
my experience whereas a 100% of the time
if I reach out to the male version of
Kate the same experiences they go like
yeah of course let's get me in so talk
to share us about that and like how you
wrestle with that how you've become
better at making sure that that internal
voice isn't Extremely Loud the yeah yeah
and I honestly think that was that in my
career is that the biggest thing that
probably does hold me back is just that
like self-doubt um but uh I think you
just got to like trust yourself and
things when you're like doing well
there's a reason it's happening it's
You' not got I genuinely was a stage I
was like it's all luck it's all luck
really yeah I actually thought it was
and um then I started to realize I don't
think it could keep happening and
happening if it was all luck um I think
why did you think it was luck
I don't know it's like I like sure like
I was like surely I can't I couldn't
have done that well I don't know I don't
know it's mad it's just a weird thing um
I think though like you you need to you
need to take when you hear stuff from
people it's like what you said before
about um noting everything down when
it's good I actually did a similar thing
where I wrote down like all the good
things not even just in work but in life
that had like gone well and wrote them
down all on my notes page and I look
back on it like oh actually if you can
remind yourself of that it's so
important um also sitting down with your
manager and getting them to talk you
through what you've done well like it's
easy to just like apart from in reviews
and stuff let that slide but actually if
you want to be like I really want to
know what I'm doing well at the moment
as well as obviously asking for
constructive feedback but then when you
hear it from them you're like oh that's
good and it just reassures you because
are you are you quite self-critical yeah
cuz I'm the same cuz like for me what I
remember if I have a conversation like
that with my manager what I remember are
the things that I can improve on rather
than the things that I did well yeah and
and you need to sometimes like battle
through that to actually get them to
tell you what you're doing well um and I
think it sometimes it is actually quite
a hard question to ask because it's like
tell me what I'm doing
girl but actually sometimes you need to
hear it from other people you do need to
hear it and it's not a bad thing to do
that or just ask like your like mate at
work or something like what do you think
and they'll be they'll bet bet they'll
tell you and you'll be like I didn't
even notice I was doing that well and
they'll tell you something do you think
this has popped into my head like I'm
just curious like do you think in your
experience do you think uh women build
each other up more or tear each other
down more God that's interesting um
build each other up do you think yeah I
actually do that's what I experien in my
company anyway I don't know about others
um but I can only speak from experience
but we're all very close at wiser and um
it's very because we've got making moves
the women in Tech Community we're just
so big on encouraging and um like
motivating women so in my in my
experience we all boost each other up
yeah I just the reason why that popped
into my head was I was thinking of
a Instagram real I was watching with uh
my partner From Grace um Beverly who
yeah do you know her right yeah and it
was just a video it just it just sort of
popped into my head cuz she was it was a
video I can't remember the video that
she was referencing but it was like this
successful woman buil of business or
whatever and then like the comment
section was a lot of women tearing
tearing her down and and these types of
things and I just thought cuz I'm just
thinking like do guys more often like
big each other up and stuff like that
but do I don't know do women do that
when Kate gets to a point where I think
oh no she's just way better than me I'm
going to I don't know I don't experience
it I like we're wiser alite are very
much like we want each other to win uh
and I I definitely wouldn't say it's the
other way around for sure yeah I just
thought cuz I was thinking again when
we're thinking about like self-doubt and
these things is it like you know do the
women face out a bit more where I don't
know they get like those little snarky
comments from people I don't know if
guys get that as much cuz guys are like
yeah [__] go on lad you're smashing
it mate I don't know if do you know what
I mean interesting it is interesting I
um it's great actually at my compan
because the the men as well are like
when I when I got top like go I love it
that's CL that's what about just I just
thought I just thinking that imp if that
impacts the things that we're talking
about yeah so what what's ahead for you
then what are you thinking going into
next year what are you doubling down on
obviously how are we feeling about
maintaining the top Bill status what we
saying I'm like looking at my name on
the board like oh god um no I think it
comes back down to the basics again like
I'm it's hard at the moment and
everyone's at quite like a similar level
um in terms of Billings Etc um but I
think as well it's easy to fall into a
trap of when you've not made a deal in a
couple of weeks you start to just be
like negative and like oh put yourself
in the like just like I'm not going to
get a deal and you get a bit grumpy
about it and stuff and it's like you
actually can't do that because it just
puts your mindset in such a bad State um
and it just comes back to WR Kate come
on like do what you do best which is
like speak to good candidates work well
with your clients and also if stuff's
not going right with the client put in
regular catch-ups weekly I think it's
easy to like when you're not being able
to send them candidates because you
can't you're struggling to find them is
to shy away and not speak to the Cent be
like but actually we found that putting
in 15 20 minutes weekly even if you have
to go on and say look I've not got
anyone at the moment but this is what
we're experiencing the Market they
actually really appreciate it so just
doing every little thing you can even if
it's not going well yeah no that's a
great tip all right well uh look forward
to finding out if we uh re the title
yeah sure you will I'll hide away if it
doesn't but no Kate thank you so much
for joining me I think kudos to you on
you know like building your
self-confidence getting to the point
where you've got to like just I'm sure
you're feeling like yeah like what else
you're capable of right which is really
exciting it's what's great about
industry like you can really push
yourself and really question like
actually if I can do this what else I
can do and I think that's one of the the
great things about our industry
definitely thank you so much awesome